on Tuesday variety released its new
cover looks like this it's a picture of
Hamilton's at bran and Victor Dixon yes
the guy who lectured Mike Pence while
pence was enjoying a night out with the
wife HBO's Lena Dunham Michael Moore
Chelsea Handler and CNN's Van Jones
they're all holding a large American
flag looking upset and somber as you can
see Dunham wears a shirt that says women
are powerful and dangerous and she seems
to hide behind the angel large more
handler wears the shirt reading let's
get to work
now what on the eve of Trump's
inauguration Hollywood in the media
raised their voices as the headline well
here's what please keep doing this
Hollywood celebrities it will ensure
that you continue to lose first off we
should never be lectured by the likes of
Lena Dunham a self-described sexual
abuser of her own sister or Michael
Moore the guy who does propaganda about
the glories of Cuba's healthcare but
more than that Hollywood seems
completely oblivious to the fact that
their shrill hysteria over Trump's
election actually drives Americans into
Trump's camp it's all abduction overawed
you're just a few of the latest
Hollywood idiot stories first the near
octogenarian members of Green Day have
released a new song tear against Donald
Trump cobbling together footage of KKK
rallies with Trump talking Billie Joe
Armstrong 44 warbles a new day dawning
comes without warning so don't think
twice we live in troubled times
meanwhile joss whedon the guy behind the
mediocre avengers flicks jokes about
paul ryan being raped to death by a
rhinoceros Nicole Kidman had the
temerity to say that the president ought
to be given a baseline level of support
and Whedon then tweeted out that she was
a quote puppet for Trump Broadway's
Jennifer Holliday she was forced out of
singing at the inauguration due to death
threats too bad she didn't lecture Mike
Pence at a show or anything then she'd
be a hero Holliday wasn't the only one
Elstad from the inauguration of her
death threats so as andrea bocelli steve
harvey he was labeled a mediocre negro
by mark Lamont Hill for meeting with
Trump over any inner-city community
development and then Hollywood wonders
why Americans don't take them seriously
on politics here's the truth at least
half of Americans feel scorned by
Hollywood and they should because
Hollywood scorns them when I researched
my book primetime propaganda I spoke
with the top creators in Hollywood
history they thought I was a leftist so
they freely admitted to discriminating
against conservatives in Hollywood and
picturing middle middle Americans as
rubes and racists and treating their
shows as propaganda outlets for their
viewpoints no wonder
Americans just get sick when they see
covers like the one from variety Michael
Moore posing with the flag is the same
guy who said that Trump supporters are
legal terrorists but actual terrorists
are Minutemen that makes most Americans
queasy treating Lena Dunham like a moral
voice despite her ardent love for
abortion and her overt bragging about
masturbating next to her 11 year old
sister in bed yeah that's sort of
nauseates Americans to acting as though
Chelsea Handler a woman who said she
should be applauded for her two
abortions as a beacon of light that's
pretty disgusting so Hollywood
keep it coming nothing drives Americans
away from leftism quite like the specter
of uber rich uber famous uber immoral
leftist treating them as direct to be
scraped from their shoes it worked so
well for Hillary Clinton she's creeping
around the woods of Chappaqua as Donald
Trump becomes the 45th President of the
United States I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
yes we have tons to get to as always it
a very exciting show planned for you
with a lot of deconstructing of culture
coming up near the end a lot of race
talk lots of stuff going on but first we
have to say thank you to one of our
great sponsors at Birch gold so if
you're interested in investing in
precious metals then Birch gold is the
way to do at Birch gold group has a
long-standing track record of continued
success they have lots of five-star
reviews they have an A+ rating from the
Better Business Bureau and they have a
free information kit on how you can
invest in physical precious metals so
it's not just you know them sending you
like a stock it's actual physical
precious metals and they have a 16 page
comprehensive kit that tells you how to
do this how to protect your savings how
you can move your money out of your IRA
or 401k into precious metals without tax
consequences they are the experts at
this birchgold.com is how to get in
touch birchgold.com slash ben and if
you're concerned about the future of the
economy and who wouldn't be considering
how volatile the economy is and will
continue to be you need to have at least
part of your portfolio and precious
metals Birch gold can help you do that
ask all your questions at birchgold.com
slash Ben birchgold.com slash Ben and
then they're the people I would trust to
invest in precious metals okay so lots
going on we begin today with the
continued racial fallout over donald
trump's inauguration so the left has to
turn everything into a racial issue it's
just imperative for them to do so and so
they continue to trot forward John Lewis
the the congressman from Georgia and the
civil rights hero to claim that Donald
Trump is not really legit it turns out
and by the way that John Lewis actually
this is the second inauguration he's
boycotting he also boycotted george w
bush's inauguration is it possible that
John Lewis is doing this not because he
thinks the Trump is illegitimate but
because he's leftist and Trump is
apparently not yeah that's that's
probable here's John Lewis explaining
not why he's boycotting Trump but why he
loves Obama no one no one's this morning
at the King jr. had inspired me the way
that Barack Obama inspire okay so if you
think that then is it any wonder that
you want to dump Trump on the side of
the road is that any shock and you can
see that there is a racial component to
a lot of the people
who are you hey Trump and it's not just
because Trump is white or anything but
what the attempt by the left is to
polarize Americans along racial lines
like Hillary was white - presumably they
wouldn't boycotted her inauguration but
there is an attempt to boycott Trump
because they're trying to draw racial
lines they're trying to say a lot of
members of the left black community
they're trying to say that the only
legitimate black people are the people
who will stand up against Trump and who
will not offer him any sort of support
or even the or even the possibility of
support in the future Maxine Waters
who's a nutcase congresswoman from out
here in California she's the one who
dubbed the LA riots the LA uprising
she's wildly incompetent she's
extraordinarily radical on racial
matters she says the Trump should be
impeached preemptively well here's what
I'm trying to get to if we discover that
Donald Trump are his advocates played a
role in helping to devise strategy if
they are the ones who came up with
crooked Hillary if they're the ones who
came up with she's ill something's wrong
with her energy and the way that he
basically you know described her in the
campaign I think that is something that
would put the question squarely on the
table whether or not he should be
impeached okay so she's talking about
impeachment and she's not the only one a
lot of Democrats very upset a lot of
them are getting ready for trouble al
Sharpton who is one of the world's great
race baiters a man who was involved in
the incitement of riots against Orthodox
Jews in Crown Heights in 1991 was
involved in incitement of riots against
something called Freddie's fashion mark
that ended with the death of several
people in an arson al Sharpton is is
still seen by the left as some sort of
racial conciliator even though he has
spent his entire career smearing people
falsely with race charges and now
Sharpton is using his platform whatever
is left of it to to rip on Trump and
suggest that he's not a legitimate
president either I think that there's no
question that the process that elected
him was not legitimate when you look at
the now evidence from the intelligence
agencies that there was the influence
from the Russians and involved in the
public discourse at the time of the
election when you look at those that
were expunged from being able to
clearly the process has a serious
questions about it
okay so you got al Sharpton doing this
routine now there are some black folks
who have met with Trump and have come
away saying some relatively nice things
about Trump so Steve Harvey met with
Trump Trump is doing a smart thing he's
inviting a lot of high-profile black
folks to the Trump Tower to try and
reach out and make overtures and suggest
that he's gonna make life better for
black Americans and not just white
Americans who voted for him in the last
election cycle and Jim Brown of course
came out after meeting with Donald Trump
he said listen
Trump won fair fair and square and I'm
going to support him as presidents of
the United States so long as I can here
is Jim Brown who met with Trump well
I'll tell you when you win against all
odds and you defeat those who were
against you and I was for Hillary so I'm
one of those who mr. Trump defeated but
he is the president-elect of the United
States I'm a citizen I'm not asking him
to do everything I'm gonna pitch in and
do some of the things that I can do with
the like-minded people that I represent
and he's in yes there's his perspective
and a Smith has said something similar
says just because you're giving Donald
Trump a chance doesn't mean that you're
doing anything racially wrong when noted
comedian and host of the hit show Family
Feud Steve Harvey exited from a meeting
with president elect Donald Trump last
week calling him quote a great man in
quote to say there was a backlash would
be a gross understatement the word cool
and sellout was immediately thrown out
his friend of contemporary DL Hughley
wasn't happy either
Amy his vitriolic Trump instead of Steve
Harvey and of course it provided the
perfect excuse for naysayers to accuse
sports greats like Jim Brown or Ray
Lewis of being used as photo ops weeks
ago but on a day like today when we
celebrate the birthday of dr. Martin
Luther King jr. along with his
undeniable historical impact perhaps
it's time for all of us to see the big
picture to essentially pay more
attention to the issues permeating our
society what it'll take to resolve them
and connecting ourselves to who we
ultimately can hold accountable rather
than focusing on disdain for that very
individual
in a position to make a difference
knowing that's not about to get us
anywhere so there are a lot of people
who hate Stephen a Smith Stephen a Smith
actually will speak truth on racial
matters farmer off and then a lot of his
compatriots on ESPN so there's there's a
small cadre of high-profile black
figures who have met with Trump and this
is driving the left baddie just as
driving them up a wall mark Lamont Hill
he's a frequent guest on fox news on CNN
all the time he's also a professor at
Morehouse College and he was in a debate
about Steve Harvey visiting Trump Tower
with a member of the of the sort of
Trump team the person he's talking to
here is is a fellow named Bruce Laval I
guess and he's the national diversity
coalition for Trump director Bruce Laval
that's the the black guy who you will
see second from the left there and then
it's Gemma green and I can't remember
the name of the the anchor here in any
case the only two who matter for this
particular conversation are the two on
the on the right hand side of your
screen and that would be mark Lamont
Hill and Bruce Laval and here is them
going at it over the fact that Steve
Harvey met with Trump Negros being
dragged in front of TV as a photo op for
Donald Trump exploitative campaign
against black people in you Mar so now
you want to name okay so he calls them
if you missed it cuz it was pretty quick
there he calls them mediocre Negroes is
what Mark Lamont Hill says there so
here's how this conversation actually
went what happened is that he'll talked
about people like Steve Harvey and Jim
Brown he said to keep bringing comedians
and actors and athletes to represent
black interest is demeaning it's
disrespectful it's condescending bring
some people up there with some expertise
Donald Trump don't just bring up people
to entertain and so Bruce LaBelle said
well you don't even know what they
talked about and he'll said well unless
Steve Harvey turned into a policy
analyst in the behind-the-scenes meeting
I mean doesn't matter whether I was
there my concern is the people he's
trumpeting up and putting in front of
the cameras and then after Lavelle said
that that was silly he'll explode he
sits a bunch of mediocre Negroes being
direct in front of TV as a photo op for
Donald Trump's exploit a to exploitative
campaign against black people and you
are a prime example of that so
Lavelle is a prime example of a mediocre
Negro being dragged in front of TV as a
photo op for Donald Trump's exploitative
campaign against black people so a few
points to be made on this number one
people on the Left do not get to
complain about Donald Trump meeting with
celebrities on political matters they
don't okay Hillary's entire campaign was
built around celebrities we showed you
that picture from variety we can bring
that up again half the people on this
cover
we're openly campaigning for Hillary
Clinton right Lena Dunham was openly
campaigning for Hillary Clinton Chelsea
Handler was openly campaigning for
Hillary Clinton Michael Moore was a
Hillary Clinton fan even though he was
more of Bernie Sanders guy the the
fellow Dixon over her I believe he
campaigned for Hillary Clinton no
problem there for the left that's
totally fine right celebrities
campaigning for Democrats that's totally
fine and you know you have Lamont Hill
saying that it's just terrible that
Trump would meet with all of these black
celebrities to push his particular
agenda for inner cities Leonardo
DiCaprio was invited to the White House
by Barack Obama to discuss global
warming just back in October Angelina
Jolie came to the White House and talked
with Obama about Sarajevo Angelina Jolie
like the Tomb Raider person right Brad
Pitt at the same time that she was
meeting with with with President Obama
Brad Pitt was talking with Vice
President Biden about New Orleans
rebuilding Brad Pitt about New Orleans
because I guess one time he'd been to
New Orleans they know no one really
understands okay during the 2008 Obama
actually sought advice on the Middle
East from George Clooney yes George
Clooney the guy from see Rihanna and
Tomorrowland right and Mark Lamont Hill
obviously had no problem with Meryl
Streep ripping on Trump it's also worth
noting by the way Martin Luther King
during that during the march on
Washington he reached out to tons of
celebrities Joseph mankiewicz and
Charlton Heston and James Baldwin and
Paul Newman and Jackie Robinson and Joan
Baez and Bob Dylan and Sammy Davis jr.
and Harry Belafonte and Ruby Dean Burt
Lancaster if you look at the pictures
who's all celebrities tons of
celebrities there are some in Selma many
in the march on Washington and the left
was fine with that so let's not pretend
that suddenly they've erected this
barrier between celebrity and politics
that's absolute nonsense
the reason Lamont Hill is really pissed
is because for the left the left is the
the entire Kenmore
superiority unearned moral superiority
of the left is based on the
unsupportable unsubstantiated belief
that they're the sole representatives of
minority interests in America that they
stand up for these discrete and insular
minorities against the evil American
system and so when there are black
people who say well you don't stand for
me then they've got a problem because it
sort of undermines their own identity
well they can trout if they can't
represent all black people then what
exactly are they representing what do
they stand for what if what if a lot of
black people say well we don't need your
help we're fine America is a good place
we hope that Trump does well well then
they get very very upset and they get to
call people mediocre Negroes it's funny
mark Lamont Hill once said that black
people are incapable of racism because
they don't have the institutional power
in order to in order to be responsible
for racism well Mark Lamont Hill
certainly has the institutional power to
be racist against Steve Harvey a race is
not politics race is not politics just
because you're white doesn't mean that
you vote because you're white according
to white interest just cuz you're black
doesn't mean you vote because you're
black according to black interests
sometimes people say well if you're
Jewish you're expected to be pro-israel
right because Judaism is an actual
religion ethnicity is not important to
me your actual religious practice is the
same thing is not true of your color
your color your birthplace none of that
matters when it comes to politics but
the left has to insist that all of that
matters when it comes to politics and so
they have to cast out all traders from
the hall and that means that obviously
people like Jim Brown and and Steve
Harvey they have to be thrown aside
because Marc Lamont Hill thinks their
mediocre Negros never mind that Steve
Harvey by the way has an audience of 4
million people on his radio show every
day and is worth about a hundred million
dollars he's a mediocre negro he's a
mediocre Negro as opposed to Marc Lamont
Hill who's tonight sat him on CNN really
quite disgusting and and racially
charged we'll get some more of that in
just a second but first we have to
direct your attention to another podcast
that you should subscribe to right now
on iTunes or stitcher or Wonder EECOM
wherever you listen to podcasts and that
podcast is called terms ok so this is a
drama podcast that's that's what it is
it's a it's a podcast that's fictional
and it's really entertaining I've
listened to it really exciting really
entertaining so political podcast sort
of a political thriller really well
produced an interesting
to listen to the basic premise is this
we voted in America votes in a really
controversial president and the two-term
exiting president decides that he wants
to do something to stop this guy from
taking office and what ensues from there
is really fascinating is constitutional
crisis the sort of manipulation that
goes on behind the scenes as somebody
who loves politics and somebody who also
loves political fiction terms is a great
piece of work and you should definitely
take a listen you can subscribe again at
iTunes stitcher Wondra com or wherever
you listen to the podcasts it really is
quite addictive so they bring out these
new episodes every Monday and so you can
listen to it every Monday as the
episodes drop they've got some back
episodes obviously available and you can
listen to those and catch up so iTunes
stitcher wandering or wherever you
listen to podcasts check it out right
now and make sure that you subscribe
okay so the Republicans react to all of
this all of this sort of race baiting in
the way that you would imagine they
would react Sean Spicer of the RNC he
comes out he says look John Lewis
started all of this you know all the
left is very upset that Trump is
attacking John Lewis John Lewis is the
one who dropped the bomb here it wasn't
Trump let's talk about the latest battle
we've just been reporting on between the
president-elect and Congressman John
Lewis the president-elect attacking John
Lewis's district his service to this
country we're looking at four days to
the run-up of the inauguration was this
the proper way to handle this or the
tamron I want to just take it back a
step Cameron because I think you know
congressman Lewis started this with your
own Chuck Todd by saying that the
election was illegitimate and that
president elect Trump was an
illegitimate president so let's see
where it started which is you have this
icon of voting in civil rights claiming
that an election was illegitimate when
there is zero evidence of that everybody
has confirmed that the election was duly
held there was no tampering with
anything and they see somebody of John
Lewis's stature and iconic nature who
has worked so hard to enfranchise people
and talk about the getting people
involved in our voting systems and and
in getting and talking about the
integrity of our voting system to then
go out when the candidate of his choice
doesn't win and try to talk about the
deal atomization of the election is
frankly disappointing okay and Sean
Spicer is exactly right now
and we're gonna have to break here on
Facebook and YouTube but in a second
we're gonna talk about why Sean Spicer
and Trump actually gets a right why
Trump is popular with Republicans and
why Marco Rubio actually gets it wrong
on John Lewis and Trump which is
something that is you know not something
I usually say usually in a fight between
Trump and Ruby I'm gonna be on Rubio
side on this one I think that Rubio is
incorrect we'll talk about all of that
over at Daily wire.com go over to Daly
wire.com become a subscriber $8 a month
if you're an annual subscriber you still
get a free signed copy of my book true
allegiance so go over and check it out
now we have a Shapiro store that's gonna
be coming shortly we're gonna have new
goodies I think we're gonna start adding
those next week at daily wire.com for
our subscribers plus you can watch the
rest of us live you can watch clayvin
live you can become part of the mailbag
which we do on thursdays and as i say
lots more goodies coming for subscribers
daily wire.com subscribe also listen to
us and subscribe to our show at iTunes
or SoundCloud and you can listen to us
every day make sure the poster review
over to iTunes tell them how wonderful
we are because if you listen you know
that we are we are the best so make sure
that you check it out we are the biggest
conservative podcast in the United
States
[Music]